Nicholas Dario versus Dan Sman and the future effects of Ethan
Klein's lawsuit. That's him sounding like he knows what goes
on at a Diddy party and this video
is going as Nick conversation. Okay. Uncomfortable question comes
up
about salt. Say something about entrepreneurial young man who
loves dogs. Oh, I disagree. No, I think he wants to destroy these
people too. And I understand why. That's just like your opinion.
That's your opinion. I if if Dan weren't so honest about the
fact that he's just willing to totally lie and it wasn't so funny
watching him do it, then I would be disgusted right now. But
I I actually find it quite funny, dude. This is just so shameful.
Like, how do you do this embarrassed like Dan? Oh my god.
I also have Nicholas Dan. Nicholas Dario versus Dan Sman and
the future effect future effects of Ethan Klein's lawsuit. Now,
I have a time stamp here that's 52 seconds in. I don't know why
I wouldn't just back this up. This is 15 minutes. Says on the
future effects, we can see what them talking about uh how they
talk about the future effects. Now, it' be very interesting,
but no clue didn't watch. Okay. I would be very interested to
see if they think or if their main point is that we can actually
through precedent say that if you state malice
that is uh that is going to have some effect on whether or not
you're guilty of copyright infringement. Found liable for copyright
infringement. Their heads on my neck. We're good. We're good.
Are they really? We're good. Here we go. Tipster paid for my
Jos pinball machine. Okay. Interesting. Um
H
I'll tell you. Do you want to make some predictions? Uh some
like side bets here on H3H3 stuff. Yes. What on pets? No, no,
no.
A pet. A pet. It's a reference to the the omnivet. Never mind.
You go. Sorry. Okay. Okay. Okay. What What are some good bets?
Chat, help us out. Some good H3 HP. I got one. I got one. So,
I was on Robin Hood and they were giving me this opportunity
to bet on a case. Never. I'm kidding. I'm kidding. I'm kidding.
I'm kidding. I'm kidding. You're You're only yourself over there.
I want you to know that. Okay. When you're like, "Why are these
guys saying this about me?" Because you did. They literally made
up that Robin Hood was hosting hyron
bets. That's hilarious.
Sorry, that wasn't a very good Italian accent. Why are they saying
that English? You just said it normally. Yeah, I know. I'm trying
to do a Nicholas Dioro Italian accent. settles first is a good
bet. Who do you think? Casey Tron. I think if Shawn gets in,
his lawsuit ends the first cuz I don't think he's actually going
to get sued. Casey Tron settling first cuz you think it's too
bad optics if she's crying? No, I think Casey Tron will settle
first because she's the most um financially self- serving of
the three and probably the most brutal and the most um You think
she's going to Oh, so you don't think that she's going to like
you think she's going to do this to get out of it and burn everybody
else in the process? She's going be like, "All right, well, I'm
done with all that communist that noise." Holy crap. Some really
funny psychological warfare by putting them all against each
other here to the point where like Denim's fired up the GoFundMe
first. That was very funny. I will say also, you should know
um in some ways they claim that he kind of parted the Red Sea
if Red was tanky. Well, now they all are competing against each
other. But I I would say look things to know. Number one, the
lawsuits cannot be combined no matter what. It's a unethical
thing. it. Not only can it not be happen even if all three defendants
wanted it to happen, it just legally can't happen because it's
in a different state for some of these things. So, okay. Well,
wait, maybe. I have no idea. Why would that matter? This will
be three separate lawsuits by three separate attorneys defending
them. Now, if I was Casey Tron, who or Froggen, honestly, cuz
really one of them, you know what it is? One of them is going
to get that quick settlement in. Whoever's first. I I I genuinely
I probably believe that that whoever is like, "Listen, I think
Caseyron probably has the strongest case for this because she
can just be like, "Listen, Ethan, I'm new to this. You see that
all of my Palestine Israel content that started like 6 months
ago? I was just trying to grift off of these dumb. Does Casey
try have a lot of Palestine Israel content? Socialist. I took
it too far. I'm sorry. You can have all of my GoFundMe money
and I promise that I will do this, that, and the other thing."
And I think Ethan will say, "Fine, [__] it. Send
it over." And that will be enough. I think that Casey Tron is
smart enough to probably do that. And I think Ethan would probably
accept it. Um,
Froggen might be in a position where she can't do that because
I think that like her whole life is built around being a Hassan
dick rider. I think
totally wrong about this. I think if Frogan comes out and goes,
"I am sorry, Ethan Klein," and gives a hard apology. That's Hassan's
moderator, bro. Her life is built. I don't know what this I don't
know why this would be relevant to anything.
Like, just uh like bring gay conversation. Do you know what I
mean? It is like literally just sucking each other off about
how epic Ethan Klein is. I just want to point out that if Ethan
Go, you finish first. I just don't understand how people can
just like Nick is just how can you not get bored? Like this guy
is literally dodging any serious criticism right now. He will
not play it on his stream. He will not talk to people. How do
you not get bored just sitting there being like, "Let's suck
each other off. What's the point? What is the point in this conversation
just
maybe if Rogan said sorry if gravel maybe maybe Ethan would forgive
them? Maybe maybe the cool epic strong would forgive them. I
need to remember that point.
Embarrassing.
But do you think I I I got to give Nick props that when Chud
called him out? I think it's like particularly impressive for
him to go, "Oh, you think I'm sucking Ethan off now? Just wait.
Just wait." Like he was not deterred one iota. Like like he basically
was like, "Oh, Chud, you think I'm doing that? Well, you know
what? If I wasn't doing that, I will do that." I personally I
would have thought that would change his uh he got upset about
it and then change nothing. So like I don't know. I don't even
know why you get upset about it to be honest with you. But um
oh I was going to say if Ethan drops the lawsuit against any
of these people because they apologized
that to me signals that he is totally malicious. is like like
all of these people have to drop all of their hope that this
was about protecting anything that this was about anything principled
that this is even about stating malice and setting a precedent
right it was it wasn't about any of that
mean petty grievance is that they accurately described Ethan
Klein as a Zionist who throats Israel
it's like yeah so I I've seen some people say this like oh if
if he just apologizes Ethan will be okay he's just got to apologize
and then Ethan will be Ethan will like forgive them and drop
the lawsuit. Dude, if that happens, this guy is the fakest on
planet Earth. It would be so sad if he if he did this and maintained
any amount of audience amongst like people who critically think.
Like in terms of like any of the commentary people, if they didn't
call him out for being like a
principalist loser, still following and agreeing with it. No,
people who critically think is still following [__]
and agreeing with it. It's just revealing quite how many people
just don't think to do so. Yeah, I know. But I don't I don't
know how you I don't know how you weave back into like, oh, actually,
if they apologize and then Ethan drops it, that's good. That
just shows Ethan's like good or merciful or something. That's
crazy to me. Like, it just shows that this was purely over hum
like he just wanted to humiliate these people. That's all he
wanted.
No, no. I think the snark people like, well, she had to do it.
She obviously didn't mean it, but uh she had to go and do that.
So, it's it's okay. And they're not going to hold it against
her. I don't think she loses anything by doing it. I think all
of them are going to treat this like nothing actually even happened.
You're delusional because I guarantee you that and as it should
any settlement that happens will have have a complete non-disparagement
clause built into it. So that means that whoever these people
are will never talk about Ethan Klein again. The only the only
disgusting in the world. By the way, you can take anything Dan
says as like Ethan Klein's actual thinking. Like I'm not I'm
not joking. Like when Dan tells you that oh well he could just
get on that's exactly what Ethan Klein is going to float to these
people. Isn't it going to say something? Surely Nick's going
to say well I mean if he forced him sign on disparagement clauses
that would certainly make it seem like it's about silence and
criticism and Ethan isn't the free speech defender that he claimed
to be. Yeah. Isn't going to say that? Surely Nick could say that
right. That's what Nick's going to say right now. Obviously.
Yeah. Like Nick Ethan's not scared of like criticism,
right? Like he's just not that that couldn't possibly be it.
One more clip that I managed to record. This one is good. Thumbnail
should summarize it. Okay. Disparagement agreements about YouTubers.
We make content on each other. That's gay. Okay. God bless. God
bless. I said there was a human left in there. There is a human.
50 50.
There is a human in there somewhere. Stop. Stop. Stop. Stop.
Listen. We don't make fun of Nick for that. Okay? If you want
to do that, Kelly has to be here and then she can do it and I
can go. Kelly, what are you doing? Kelly, stop. Kelly, don't.
Okay? That's what That's what we have Kelly here for. That's
standard [__] bro. If you want If you want me not
to sue you, but that's why I don't like this [__]
But why can't Nick apply that to like suing people over copyright
in the first place? Well, listen, he he he stood some ground
here. Okay, you got to give it to him. Got to give it to him
when he Yeah. Yeah. disparagement agreements about YouTubers.
We make content on each other. That's gay. That's standard [__]
bro. If you want If you want me not to sue you, That's why I
don't like this [__] dude.
So, I can't talk about anything that Ethan Klein ever does again.
If he sued me and I'm trying to get out of this situation that
censorship,
it's okay. God bless Nick. Oh my god. These sense should be saying
it's against free speech. Okay, Nick, listen. It's It's still
okay. Deep down, I see there's still someone in there.
It's just the funny thing is is I know that Dan and Ethan are
very close. I know that Dan and Ethan talk a lot. That's why
Dan has the redact.dev
censorship button on the stream now on like their podcast and
right. They're very close. When Dan is saying this, he is effectively
testing the waters for these things that he's telling Ethan,
right? Like this is what Ethan wanted out of this to get non-disparagement
clauses to stop the criticism. That's what he wants more than
anything in the world. Yeah. After you stole his video while
saying that you wanted to keep people from having giving us money.
Not specifically.
Sorry, Nicholas. Sorry, Nicholas. normalize. You're an enemy
nor No, he didn't. He said he didn't want the video. He just
said that they knew that they would. That's it. You didn't. You
listened to it. You know exactly what I Yeah, that's what he
said legally, but you know, he wanted them to do that to fall
in the trap. I don't think so. If it was an easier way to go
about it, he would have sued them for I think he definitely would
have preferred to have an extra 100,000 live concurrent views,
which would have boosted the out of his video in the algo. So,
who had 100,000 views? Oh, I disagree. No, I think he wants to
destroy these people, too. And I understand why that's just
that's your opinion. But also, even if you're right, normalize
destroying people who are trying to destroy you. Normalize fighting
back. You're doing the team sports thing. That's the part I don't
like. It's not team sports. If you're punching me in the face,
I'm going to the people. Normalize the people like that are trying
it. It's It's very like team sport. I didn't say normalize the
normalize punching someone back if they punch you. Sure. That's
it. Yes. Sure. But there has to be a limit to how like how hard
I think
non-disparagement can never talk about me again. If it's can
never talk about this again or something or or can never [__]
go. This is the first time I've actually heard Nick put a limit
on his support for Ethan. What he usually does is he will say
I'm not sure if I support that yet. We'll see. But never actually
sets the limit of like exactly what will make his mind set like
what the limits are. This is the first time I have heard him
say this is a limit to my support for Ethan Klein if he makes
some I don't agree with that.
Yeah. Yeah. It's like the criticism, right? Like he has he hadn't
been doing it and now I feel like he's realizing that he won't
have I legitimately think a lot of it is the um is like some
of the I bet it's because of Auggie. It might be. It could be
that he watched um it could unironically be that he watched that
stream with Straight Raid and Auggie and it could be cuz I think
I think at some point this should also be like a warning sign
for Ethan Klein and some other people right like like Nick has
yes exactly as Quman said not stated like where he draw the line
now he's drawing a very clear line like hey you signed non-disparagement
agreements like I am off the boat right I think it's
off the boat, but he's saying that would be gay. He's saying
that he wouldn't agree that you can't, you know, that's not how
they should work. But yeah, saying censorship.
I'd say this this change up to me seems like like it should be
concerning to Ethan where it's like, hey, you're starting to
go far enough that people are like they're starting to set up
conditions for like disavowing or distancing from you. That should
get concerning. I feel like you've you've been like playing with
house money for so long. You've been able to do whatever you
want. Nobody really criticizes you. Oh, but the skulls. owe the
Nazi sword, right? And now suddenly people are like re-engaging
the critical thinking. Not good if you're Ethan Klein. Not good
for you. Be critical of him in any capacity ever again is too
far. You still here? Is AFK. Can you hear me? Sorry. Oh. Oh,
you pulled the mic out again. Yeah. Sorry. Uh, if you prefer,
we can do 150k plus attorney fees in court. I mean, I think that
would be more rep. I think that would be better. that that's
your that's your generally I think making them povert like literally
putting them into poverty would be better than making so they
can never here's the thing that that is their choice to take
uh no it wouldn't that's actually significantly more psychotic
I don't understand I get like the principle for free speech but
I don't understand like the like people who just advocate or
are fine with financially destroying other people over talking
is just crazy to me yeah it's just wild sure what I would say
100% and if they do that that's on them but I just I That is
on that is on them. That is on them. I think that if Ethan's
looking to make sure they never talk about him again and using
it that way. No, I don't I don't think he gives a if they talk
about I don't even think that's what he's doing. Like
a non-disparagement agreement until you said it. No, but I'm
not saying that he is going for that. I'm just saying what is
normal in a settlement NDA non-disparagement agreement. Yeah.
Non-disclosure agreement. problem. If all these YouTube people
start doing lawsuits and and sign non-disclosure agreements,
I'm not destroying the entire YouTube drama ecosystem that's
fundamentally built off of me responding to you, you responding
to me back and forth. It completely blows up the entire community.
Well, as I said, I don't I actually don't understand where this
opinion comes from that we didn't have it for Denims the Denims
reacts. I actually I don't get it. said, "Good thing you have
Ethan Klein, your hero that is doing this and not me." Okay.
Because if it was me, then you should be concerned. Again, we're
talking purely in hypotheticals right now cuz there are people
who are taking this weight. That is never going to happen. It's
like, well, that was the prompt that I was given. Yeah. I I like
to be clear so everyone knows none of this is going to happen
at all. There will be no precedent. thing is going to be settled
but I'll be like there's no there's nothing that's happening
non-disclosure agreement for allations
yeah we're talking completely here in like you know what could
be situation the reality of this situation is very simple the
we're not we're not Dan is absolutely in Ethan's ear Dan is absolutely
advocating that Ethan get non- non-disparagement clauses from
these people hey Ethan you know how you really say you can't
disparage this um I
You're just like spinning up anti-mitting conspiracy theories
that Dan and Ethan are talking. Give me proof of that. Yeah.
Dan the redact dev button and Dan agreeing that it did happen
that he was in contact and Ethan also agreeing in the conversation
with the son that they were talking. Yes. That means Dan controls
him cuz you're anti-semite. Yeah. Dan controls others. That is
an anti-semitic conspiracy theory. Yep. Yep. Yep. Wow. JQ main.
Wow. Exactly. Wow.
Wow. Wow. Wow. Oh my god. What the wow.
Wow.
Three of these people are completely like completely and there
is no there's not going to be any precedent that's going to be
set from this because it's just you give a suggestion on what
would have been better recourse for handling this on Ethan's
side without involving lawyers under the assumption he legitimately
has received a harassment. Harass back. That's like literally
what he's done his entire career. Yeah, for real. He knows exactly
what it is. He just doesn't like that he was losing. He doesn't
like that he wasn't winning. He wasn't like clearly winning this
time. That's That's the problem, right? It's not that It's not
that he doesn't like harassing people. It's not that he's never
harassed people. He does it. He's He's erroneously absolutely
implied or called people. He's Ethan Klein's has never been harder
than the one time he pulled up that that commenter the commenter's
Instagram that like made a negative comment on Ela's Instagram,
right? He pulled that up on his like 50,000 concurrent viewer
live stream and like flipped through pictures of that guy's family.
His has never been harder than that moment. He absolutely.
He He never He never is happier than when he's harassing people.
He's just not winning. I It's That's all it is. Why you got to
talk about his Oh, sorry. His was harder. Absolutely. When he
was like, "If if Taylor Loren apologizes, then I will drop the
lawsuit against Shan the Black." if she apologizes on the times
to someone. So gross, dude.
I'm pretty sure he also encouraged viewers to contact that person's
family and workplace when he did that. I'm serious. Yeah, he
loves harassing people. He just doesn't like that he's not winning
or that he's not like overtly winning this time. That guy complained
that he was getting his sister was getting threats and they like
laughed or some [__] as well. I'm pretty sure didn't
give a [__] You love to see it. just like these were
in front of the Avengers uh premiere like selling bootleg copies
saying don't give money to Disney here you go like that there's
no precedent to be set it's just they they're so there won't
be any precedent set probably most of them will try to settle
and it'll be very funny cuz all the Wait why is Dan saying there
won't be like selling bootleg copies saying don't give money
to
go ahead cuz I'll settle well I thought I thought he was saying
no no it's like bootleg copies. So, it's like the same thing
during the premiere. Going to be any precedent that's going to
be set from this because it's just like these were in front of
the Avengers
uh premiere like selling bootleg. No, they weren't. Most people
found that through YouTube. None of them were advertising on
YouTube to go to somewhere else. Copy saying, "Don't give money
to Disney. Here you go." Like that. No, that's absolutely not
at all what they were doing. That's just a total lie. In fact,
the complete avoidance of the YouTube platform is probably going
to be the one of their strongest arguments against the market
replacement thing. There's no precedent to be set. It's just
they they're so there won't be any there's ton of precedent to
be set here. Precedent set. Probably most of them will try to
settle and it'll be very funny cuz all the GoFundMe money is
going to go directly to Ethan as I said it would. which is why
make sure that we continue to get people to donate to their campaign
because they're still even as I say this and I tell you guys
this not have a good success rate. So the more he talks about
this the more I'm like maybe they've got maybe they've got a
good chance dude. Uh Dan getting bets out on the Dan Clansancy
thing that would have been free money. I I had every inclination
to like bet against him and I didn't. How much did uh what
I saw I saw like some I had like faith. I was like I was like,
"Yo, I think this dang guy might actually [__] these
people up and it just didn't happen." I was like, "Hey, well,
I got told I got told about like all the companies that had pulled
their advertising and I'm like, there's no way Twitch will keep
their CEO if this is true." I don't even think I got lied to.
I was just I was surprised that they kept their CEO through all
of that. It was very interesting. Have to make up your Kimal
losses. True. But yeah, I think I think a guy in Spicy Chat made
like a a grand or something betting with Dan on Dan. a grand.
Yeah. Yeah. Jesus.
And this will get clipped and they're not going to No, this is
why it's like it's like interdimensional chess. I don't make
to sound smart because it just it's impossible to know when we
say encourage them to counter redact. What? He donated it to
the um the counter redact.
I forgot that he did that. You're right. He was like, "Here you
go." You sent it to some Oh, I don't want to entrepreneurial
young man. Okay. I was going to say something about entrepreneurial
young man who just loves paws. Okay. He just loves paws. Pausing.
Pause. He just loves them. Loves dogs. He loves recording messages
to donate to the GoFundMe. We really win either way to be completely
honest with you. Either they have unfunded GoFundMes which makes
them look like sad and they can't defend themselves and it's
like not good like oh wow the whole socialist community could
only raise 30k for these people. It's either that and you win
or the other way that you win is they donate a ton of money.
All campaigns get funded completely and all of that money goes
to Ethan Klein. Like it is literally a winwin across the board.
I just want personally I would rather that they have um they
raise more money. I think that would be way better personally.
Someone I responded with chatter. They said uh but that doesn't
that already happen bigger Ethan Klein listen Ethan Klein's wins
in either case. I just think he wins harder if they actually
raise all the money guys. But Ethan can't lose. Ethan will win
no matter what. YouTubers crushing scare smaller YouTubers into
silence. I think that there are above board ways that are fair
to do that. Um, I think that if you're a large YouTuber and somebody
calls you out and you on them in response and your video is good
and you're doing it above board, I think that is like the I think
that's a unfortunate or fortunate depending on what your what
your position on that is way of accomplishing that goal. I think
that uh threatening to bankrupt somebody and uproot their entire
life over something like that if not I I think you need a very
specific set of things to happen where I would think that that's
okay. You know, I think these people I don't think that these
people should be going to threaten. No, it shouldn't. It shouldn't.
This is a very specific case. Anybody here specifically if every
YouTube drama was settled with court threat? No, that would be
concern notice settlement.
The funny thing is though, what we can say for sure is Ethan
Klein's willing to risk that to go after these people, right?
Like they're talking about this and it's Ethan is the is the
first mover here. He's the person that's willing to risk this
world existing.
Everybody else is just going to follow along now, right? So,
even a case like this, this should literally cost you all respect.
Like, nobody who's like
um engaged in sort of thing should ever give you any [__]
kind of respect. You should be like spat on. You should be like
less than dirt. Say, "No, you you you had issues with people's
videos and comments about you. instead of settling it with response
videos and comments, you had to bring down the whole thing or
you tried to bring down the whole thing over it. So, do you think
you does he think doesn't get harassed? Does he think's life
isn't like the same kind of if you want to call his life hell?
Does he think
nothing in return? She gets like 200 viewers. She gets all in
return. She like barely makes her rent. She like barely makes
her. That's what she does. I literally rent goals on her stream.
Just rent dono goals. Pay my rent for next month. Please help
me. Please, please. H like. But Ethan will sit there and and
like Yeah. He's like, "Dude, my life is so I'm getting harassed
so much by these people." It's so funny that XC mind dropped
this guy into liking watches, too. That's like the funniest thing
is XQC being like, "I got your house on my wrist. I got your
house on my wrist." Literally turned this guy into like a big
watch loser. I think I've I don't know if I've met somebody who
isn't a watch maker, who's into expensive watches, who isn't
like a totaling loser. I don't know. I don't know if I've met
I I have like one guy I've gulped with a couple times that is
literally a watch maker and he's got like a $50,000 watch and
he makes like $50,000 watches and that's the only guy I've ever
known with like an expensive watch. Who would have been a total
prick? I I don't know. I'm sure they exist, but I it it just
seems it's like a level of ostentatiousness that just is never
required. Neither party can ever talk to each other ever again.
This community would grind to a halt. It would end in a week.
Yeah. No, I I completely agree. I don't think we're going that
this would be an effective strategy. That's it. It's over. Um
I feel like we should all have a lot of criticism for the person
who is threatening to turn it into that because they don't like
that other people were mean to them. I think we should all have
the fact that you are risking, the fact that you are pushing
for that to be the case should cost you everything. It should
be it should be on other people to make sure that the price of
doing this is worse than whatever benefit you receive. And in
fact, just like you said, just like you're saying, it should
actually be you should be doing it before it goes anywhere before
any of these people settle. You should be like actually transparently
telegraphing to Ethan Klein, hey uh actually you forever if you
go through with this. If you settle with these people, if you
get non-disparagement clauses, if you're like just trying to
like bully these people into silence, yeah, you forever. It's
it's over. Yeah. And if you're not doing that, you're probably
making the wrong you're you're acting, you know,
in a fundamentally like unprincipled way or in a way with like
uh the wrong principles, I guess. If you're into YouTube commentary,
YouTube criticism. I don't think it's over. But yeah, I I agree
with people saying like, "Oh, well, if they don't call CPS, they
don't get sued." Yeah, that's precisely my point, though. Yeah,
like I think that that is a question. Who called CPS? Who called
CPS? When did Ethan Klein plan this? When did CPS actually get
called? Hey, totally timeline here. The timeline is totally wrong
because the trap is set long before CPS is even called. It's
so stupid. His mind state for why he wanted to register it. And
by the way, I never mind. Uh
there's like Hold on. I I need to check. Hold on. I'm sending
you a message. I don't remember. I I not It doesn't really matter,
but it's like I Ethan himself. All you need is Ethan himself
said I registered this stuff because I wanted to make a piece
of content that these people I knew they it'd be too juicy for
them to avoid. They'd react to it and then I could sue them.
Like that was before CPS. That was way before CPS. We don't have
to lie about it. We just we shouldn't lie about it. Nobody should
be lying. But actually, it might not be because again, he did
this Library of Congress [__] before CPS even happened.
So then that that's a I didn't even realize that when I was covering
Oh, Nick's self. Oh my god. Through time and space, we're helping
we're helping Nick We're helping
My [__] brain right now. I love it. It's awesome.
The first time this was set in stone way before it escalated
that far. Yes. When were the skulls? Uh, it was after CPS. After
CPS. No, it's one of idiot. When was CPF?
Um after they
which was much after it was full of sometime around like 20th
February almost like three and a half weeks. Three three and
a half weeks. Way after the we're talking about over a month
after the content Nick. Yep. So I didn't know that. It's crazy.
It's been like it's been like six month. Well honestly I feel
like it's been since like October november. A lot of stuff has
h we've been covering this story like I said this is a story
that keeps on giving. Honestly, you know, as a as a fellow commentary
YouTuber, this has been this has been great, honestly. Well,
that's the thing. It's like I'm having a great time. I love covering
this. This is very funny. Um, a lot of the people I hate are
finally getting like their Just Desserts, but I also don't want
it to be the last time that we ever cover YouTube drama ever.
So, that I don't future for YouTubers. I I definitely don't listen.
Uh, we're only risking that, dude. This is like um Ethan Klein's
sitting here and Ethan Klein is like launched an ICBM said there's
a nuke on it. Okay. And we're sitting here being like well it's
not guaranteed that there's a warhead on it. Okay. It could be
like a decoy. It could just be like making us think he's launching
a nuke. Okay. It's not guaranteed that he's launching a nuke,
guys. So until we see the nuke land, should we really act like
he's launching a nuke even though he's like kind of said as much
kind of said he doesn't care about the consequences. Should we
really care? Should it really be that big a deal? Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah, the the the thing he's doing is bad. Regardless of whether
or not it has the the um downside consequences, taking the risk
in the first place is what is the bad behavior? That's the bad
behavior.
Please criticize the bad behavior. Don't think that that's going
to be the goal to like as much as it regardless of whether he
makes him sign non-disparagement agreements, the goal is blatantly
quelling criticism. You shouldn't like that that behavior, you
should be against on principle if you're if you have this perspective.
But h yeah, I don't I think I think Nick's against this stuff,
but there are a lot of people in like the commentary YouTube
space who do not like criticism who explicitly like seek to quell
criticism, right? Like I would say that when Chud throws out
his little comment and then there are people who are acting like
Chud is a total snake for doing this, I would say that's a reaction
to like quel criticism. We don't want you to speak your mind.
We don't want you to actually say your criticism. Why don't you
take that into private? Okay. I think it's the same instinct,
just obviously not doing it legally. Obviously way better, by
the way. Way less way less annoying when you just say it in a
YouTube video. But that seems to be like the goal in a lot of
ways is uh listen guys, we're all making a bag. Don't [__]
up the bag. Don't up the bag. I mean, the thing like you're you're
totally imagining like the absolute worst case scenario of what
could possibly happen. But I think I also represent the large
percentage of the commentary audience who's worried about well
not audience the commentary YouTubers who are worried about this
and it could be unjustified. Sure 100%. But that's the one that
you're the only one thinks about. You're the only like the only
big one that mattered like who else is like live stream YouTube
commentary like this like drama YouTuber. Everyone quit. It's
just me. It's Chud Dix. Okay,
he's such a passive aggressive little [__] He did
say well he said Chud. I thought he was gonna I I It's so funny.
There's nobody else though. There is literally no one else. It's
crazy he doesn't actually get mocked for stuff like this. He's
so He gets off so light. This is actually This is actually cooler.
At least this is him just being himself. Okay. So yeah, someone
should be palming the top of this guy's head every time this
happens.
Quit. Yeah. So, but you have And I'm And I'm for the most part
on board, so it's not really But like Okay. So, you're just like
I'm going through reservations. I have for sure. Okay. I think
um Dan's done nothing to Dan's done nothing to um assuage Nick's
like concerns about this either. It's literally like we we just
know it would be insane if they didn't fold. They're going to
fold, guys. They're going to blink and they'll they'll settle
and nothing will happen. Okay, why why would why would we just
assume that? Um at some point, you know what we're going to see
is uh Asmin Gold funding these settlements. Okay, as Asenold
is the only person who has the financial incentive to make sure
that this president doesn't go through and enough extraneous
money as gold or XQC to just be like, you know what, Denim's
here. Just pay him 100 grand, okay? Make this go away. 100 grand.
It's It's over. We're good. We're all good, guys. Nope. This
president is not going to be um is is uh Kai Sorry, this is totally
I'm being totally ADHD re like this is total. Is Kai Clips making
content again? Yeah, he's Well, he's back from uh his mission.
his mission. Oh [__] Wait, you you know he's a Mormon,
right? That's why he stopped making Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. I did that. Yeah. He went on like a two-year mission or
something. And he was I think he back from it like six months
ago or something. Maybe a year ago. I don't know if he went back.
I thought he was He is such a good person to go after Dean Withers.
That's That's awesome. He's going Oh, is he doing that? Yeah,
he was on a call with him earlier. Apparently, he got kicked.
Oh, that's funny. Oh, that's funny. He is like Negadine, you
know. No, I don't know. I love Kai Cliff, man. He's
I like Kai Cliffs. Yeah, Kai is funny. And he used to just absolutely
just lay into Stardust sometimes. It's so funny. He's a funny
guy. But the weird thing is I could have sworn he came back from
his mission like a year ago or more. So I thought I thought he
wasn't going to make content again. I thought he like came back.
Now I'm not doing it. Probably. I would imagine. But Oh, hold
on. Let me uh I'll fix the overlay. Kenny's way too big for the
overlay.
Pause. No, not pause. Hold on. Do I have a Do I have another
Kenny avatar? I don't even know. Hold on. I might have to fix
this. Why? He's been streaming. I streamed two days ago. What
does he stream? I mean, what does he stream? I don't know what
he streams. He streamed like 19 minutes last time. Why does he
stream? Oh, Cozy. I haven't checked anywhere else. Oh,
he probably just streams on Cozy. Let's keep watching. I think
we're aligned. Restart his YouTube for the most part. I think
we're aligned, but I think that we're I I definitely aligned.
We're on a parallel position more. I This is the one. This is
This is This is
This isn't brutal cuz it feels like Dan's like, "We're on the
same team and Nick's like, I think we're aligned. Let me watch."
For the most part, I think we're aligned, but I think that we're
I I we're definitely aligned. We're on a parallel course position
more. I understand your position. Oh, you're you're you're scared.
You're scared to say it. Tell me where we differ. All you say
is I'm worried. I'm You know what? Actually, I'm worried show.
So, I don't want to spoil anything. I'm wor I'm worried, too.
I'm worried too, actually. Boom. I think that I am 446
456 and you're the front man. And if you guys watch that show,
you will understand what I'm talking about cuz I got spoiled
on Twitter today. I don't know what the you're talking about.
I think that you are the front man and I 456. 456.
My new Fortnite skin. Use code Doro in the item shop. Let's go.
Sorry. It was a Squid Game reference. How did they make a second
season of that? Third season came out yesterday. I can't be they
watch this like how how the second season and third season are
one big season that they split in half and called it two seasons.
It's just like honestly it's better that you didn't watch it
yet. Watch it back to back. I haven't seen the third season just
to be clear. So it's not really much for me. Classic Nick conversation.
Okay. Uncomfortable question comes up. Pop culture. Think about
your spoil. I just got spoiled on Twitter of of like one plot
point. Why? Someone says Dan has a cat in a box vibe and I can't
be mad about it. Actually kind of dig a box vibe. I don't know,
but they said it. And you know what is that when they have kittens
and they like box of kittens? I don't know. Scroll up in your
chat. It's Dan has a cat in a box vibe. Flamco. Do you think
he's dead? How would you I actually Flamco. Oh, take a shot.
Flamco reference. Okay. It's a conversation Nick's having on
stream. Flamco has to be brought up. Let's go. Is no you don't
know fl you've never seen like his debates with I actually I
was googling it and did you know that flamco is a Spanish art
form originating in andia known for its passionate expression
and intricate rhythms
Ethan Ralph's uh former co-host who sold him out when Zoom threatened
to dox him and then he became the biggest Ethan Ralph a log until
the day that he up and leaked his email and then people found
out a ton of about him during Ethan Ralph's kill killstream
kingpin invitational
the you know I was there for the start of all that stuff you
know like that's how long I've been there for a while too yeah
yeah but I was there at I was there when the sacred books were
first written I was there when you didn't show up at the Tonka
fight yeah yeah I was there too I was there yeah it was awful
my first two videos on YouTube after the nerd city one do you
know I did a DN D with Ethan Ralph okay nobody cares about the
end of this okay I got one more none of these 22 minutes god
that's a
That's a lot. Dan Salt and Nick discuss Hassan's allegations.
Okay, this is definitely this definitely got to be I feel like
this is the conversation made for Nick to push back in, right?
You ever heard I feel like Nick's going to know some of these
things are like totally made up anymore. Yeah. I like Do you
know like the cognitive dissonance from Hassan's audience? So
I like this is just a funny thing, okay, but I want to go over
it again. Hassan is a guy who's on record that he's prostitutes.
He's a guy on record saying that he wanted to Diddy's castoffs.
He's a guy on record. Whoa. When the did he say that? You don't
know about this? I don't know. Hassan did not want to lather
up in baby oil and start people at Diddy's house. Hold on. This
is like totally meaningless. Dioro, are you with me right now
or are you with me? That didn't happen. No. No. No. No. Stop.
No. No. Stop. Stop. Stop. Stop. Stop. Stop. Stop. Stop. up. Hassan
wanted to Diddy's castoffs. What is a cast off? Is that like
Take Off the Rapper? Are you with me right now? Are you trolling
me? I That was a joke, but I actually I have no idea what you're
talking. Wait, there is proof that that I think Hassan made a
tweet that was like, "Oh, I'd be so lucky if I got the off like
Diddy's like sloppy seconds or some [__] like that."
2012. Yeah. Yeah. Before any white person knew about the Diddy
stuff. Okay. Yeah. And like seven years before he went to the
thing they call a Diddy party. Yeah. talking about and I had
to stop you because that sounds crazy. There's a clip of him
talking about young girls. Okay, I have no idea. No, no, no.
We're sorry. We're have to extend this conversation a little
bit. I'm sorry. I have to pull up argue was that he went to a
party and he's like this is cringe or whatever and he found out.
You suck as a drama YouTuber. You're all over the place, man.
Bro, there's the diddy. What is the diddy party alleg? I didn't
spend two seconds looking Give me a second. I can't, you know,
I can't believe you didn't spend two seconds on this. What is
wrong with you? What is [__] wrong with you? You
call yourself an honorable drama YouTuber and you didn't cover
this. Are you okay? This better this better be better than the
clip I pulled of you. You paid
is paying.
Uh oh. Dan Dan's over overplaying again. Pan came for his throat
and now Nick's like, "Actually, Dan, you're a actually Dan
to not watch this. I'm actually getting paid from both sides,
dude. That's how I I maintain my uh That's how I maintain my
my wealth, dude. Here, here is the video that I made. I'm going
to post it in your chat because it's the best one. You think
Dan made Oh, wait. Dan might have made this. Dan does like edit
some things sometimes. Not often, though. Of course, we're going
to get So, Dan is sending me his own self-promotional material.
It's on an H3 subreddit, and I didn't even post it. So, one of
these jacked it from me. Are you going to sue them? Thinking
about it. Well, why aren't you going to sue them and defend your
IP, Dan? Is it cuz I didn't register? I didn't think I didn't
I didn't think call animal control on your cat. I didn't think
ahead enough ahead enough to register
animal. My content, dude. He logged He logged my stream in the
Library of Congress and said it was his. All right, I'm I can't
show the tweet cuz he didn't send it yet. I got to link in chat.
You dumb. You're so stupid. We have DMs, bro. What are you talking
about? Here. God, Dioro, you are your YouTuber skills is It would
be amazing. Max, you just pointed out, but it would be amazing
if we could just have, as Dan did this, it's like, wait, don't
you run a stream with a guy who like called a 15-year-old like
nearly irresistible, like he was going to get over cuz all these
15-year-olds sending him foods were just too hot. Isn't that
the guy you like do a podcast with? Am I crazy? Isn't that Leaving
something, bro? I'm not looking at my chat. All right, now pull
I want to watch it at the same time. I want to hear the audio.
I'm going to screen share. I'm going I am going. And you have
to start at the beginning, too. Okay, Mr. Salt Man. Dang guy
like a child. Let's go. I didn't hear it yet. I made this YouTube
video. It's so good. I made it. I did all these sound effects.
I did the editing myself. Everything. First, stop. Pause. Watch
the video or watch the first scene. What does that say? Read
it out loud. Wait, I'm pretty sure you guys for this like spicy
or something and like left. How would you post this in spicy
going to dap you off? What? Yeah. And everyone's like calling
like a boomer and saying it was a gay lame edit. And dude, oh
my god, I'm pretty sure I remember this. Read it out loud. Godamn
it. I don't want to read that. No, I don't want to read your
best.
Read it in your best
would love. Should I make Carl Weezer say it? That do it. Jimmy's
mom would love to hang with Diddy at the Saraka garage and trickle
down and beg anything thrown at his way, dude. All right, now
press play. All right, bro. Was he like 12 when he wrote this?
How old was this? He wrote this. He wrote this. He wanted the
people that Diddy was Didd diddy parties.
But he didn't know that Diddy was
children.
Hold on. Okay, let's get ahead of Don't get ahead of yourself.
Let's press play on this. Why is he trying to imply that these
things are connected? Hassan commenting on it like eight years
later. Video. What? So weird. Why'd he say what loud? Hold on.
I got to make this louder. Boost it. Because he was reading the
tweet um that I So no, sorry. He was responding that I Look at
my tweet. Look at my tweet. That's me. The cat at the top. I
wrote
I got nothing you just said. Quan, what's up? I was saying this
is painful. Can I get to the point? Of course I'm This didn't
happen. I just like watching We've watched like multiple clips
of just Dan not really selling people on the things. He's he's
like he's there. He's trying to sell some stuff and he's just
not not getting it done. Really like the anti- stereotype when
you think about it. Okay. You'd think it's literally acts like
a caricature, you know? Do you see it coming? We should pull
up some of his D and D stuff with Son again where he's like the
super anti-semitic tropes. He's just like every anti-semitic
trope in one character. Actually up the campaign because he like
every time they go to a shop he's like I have to negotiate. I
have to do it. And what are you talking about? Think. So he's
saying the tweet's fake even though it's an archival. No, no,
no, no, no, no. Stop. You are Stop. Go back. Like how are you
this up? You are the worst at context. Okay. First off, this
is a tweet that happened in 2012. Okay. Okay. Now, press play
and I'm going to tell you to pause again quick after that. This
is like con what? Pause. Okay. Okay. Okay. He's now responding
to someone who's saying, "Are you denying that you've gone to
a diddy party?" Okay. Now, this tweet does not say that he's
gone to a diddy party that he did. It just says that he wants
to people that have come down from a diddy party. Okay. Okay.
So, someone just asked him, "Hey, are you denying that you've
been to a diddy party?" Well, he didn't want to them. He wanted
to give them the bro tip. Stop, you dumb bastard. They were trying
to be funny in chat. Okay. They were Hassan Nick just made a
joke that agrees with Dan and Dan didn't get it and Dan doesn't
understand and now Dan is Nick Rider being like, "Oh, so Hassan,
so you're saying you've never been to a diddy party, lol." He
wanted to give them the bro tip is saying like his the tip of
his and it's bro tip because that was Hassan's segment. Oh, of
course they're
never mind. Okay, I got you. How am I having to explain this
to you? No, I
just press play. Press play. But this guy's a madchild. He's
an actual mad child. It's so funny. I ain't going to a Did he?
By the way, if Dan were watching this for some reason at 4:30
in the morning, Eastern time, you could just join the stream.
I don't think he's watch. I think this is actually too late for
him this time. I do know that he watches a lot though. It's good
times. Party. You're watching right now having a late night in
your episode. Feel free to jump on. Okay, you always can. You're
always welcome. You have the permissions. You're in the Discord.
Could happen. Didn't happen. What are you talking about thing?
I did that editing. Oh, look at you with the T channel music.
Yeah, you thought it was a compliment. You I got you. I walked
into this like back like sphere Epcot looking thing in the in
the back of like the house that P Diddy was renting for his Ooh,
okay. and was throwing after parties at at Coachella and they
were playing like these crazy Yeah, this is the crazy things
for people who are watching. Not me. I had only eaten porttoella.
Oh, I think this is He's also clip chimped, I'm pretty sure.
Bro, he's in the room where he slams the desk. I'm sorry. And
one of the images that they were playing was like this little
girl, this like supposedly attractive, very young. All right.
Supposedly attractive. He's criticizing the age of the girl.
He's there at the diddy party. Okay. No, no, no. Dan. Dan, you
told me he was attracted to young girls. This is a video of him
saying that he wasn't attractive. Hold on. When did I say that?
I that's not that's not the way that you said it, but you implied
that he was happy about this young girl and said that she was
hot. He specifically saying supposedly attractive that he was
hot. I do not recall saying anything like that. Sir, you are
putting slanderously
young girls. He said he wanted to young girls. That's what claimed.
Imagine being upset about a a popular shrimmer wanting to young
girls. Imagine. Imagine that. It's almost like that should be
a principle that follows through your podcast co-host. No.
Yeah. Wouldn't you think so? Wouldn't I I feel like that would
make sense. The way I the way I explained it the first time.
Please, Nicholas, please. I know Nicholas knows about that too
for a fact cuz I've heard it be explained to Nicholas directly.
So, it would be so funny if you could just point this out right
now. It didn't come out good. The point is he's this is not a
positive for him. He He wasn't like, "Wow, this minor is [__]
very
girl like opening up a Christmas gift." Okay, so now So there's
more. I'm sorry. There's more. Did you think that was it? No,
there's more. That was the only clip that I'd seen, but it sounds
like he was really happy to All right. If Dan goes to the brothel
thing next, I'm probably just going to end the stream there.
Oh, no. He was happy to be there, but he's now like not explaining
it. So, I have more for you, though. Okay. Um, so what is he
on? Am I crazy? How am I going to find this quickly? The big
thing here is that he went to a diddy party. Not anything related
to because you're talking about like
and stuff. Ion mushrooms at Coachella. He walked into like the
tent or some for a diddy party, right? Is that that's what I'm
getting out of
Oh, maybe the next clip will be where Hassan says he doesn't
want his girlfriend at a diddy party, right? Maybe that'll be
the next one. No, I'm just saying. Hold on. I'm looking at the
grand the way that this is the way that this is structured is
did he wanted to Diddy's entourage and then the clip that you
play is him saying that there was like a supposedly young girl
at the event. So obviously like on a video not literally there
I don't think that he was into the young girl. You don't know
though? I don't know either. I assume but I don't think there's
any evidence that can even let me imply that that could be the
case. Well, let's uh hold on. Let's let's let's take a look see
here. Let me sort this by uh sort by dates. Old to new
is not there.
What's that? This next one's going to be a kill shot. I can tell
for sure. Definitely not a nothing burger. Definitely not. Definitely
not. Definitely not. They're like this is Dan has never oversold
something like this ever before. So there's no reason to believe
that he would be overselling it now. Okay. Just whack. I mean
listen to what he just said. girl. This like that they were playing
was like this little girl. This like supposedly attractive very
young girl. That is him literally saying it's whack. He was at
a diddy party. It doesn't matter if he's saying it's whack. I
get that. I understand
party. Well, but you have achieved funding for one of your companies
from P Diddy though, haven't you, Dan? Though I would say
far less material support. Isn't that Dan's big line in the sand
showing material support for bad actors? Okay. You're like, "Didn't
didn't that platform have a reputation for endangering miners?"
And they have a quite widespread reputation for Wait, do you
have proof of something like that? I don't know. Would you would
you have proof of something like that? Oh, do I have proof of
something like that? Well, let's just You never make that accusation
about tiny chat grooming
Ooh.
Ooh. Isn't this Dan guy your friend? You want to bury him? Should
be nice. Looking good. Listen, I'm just trying to remain We're
trying to hold Dan to his own principles, okay? For his own sake.
That's all. I agree with you. I'm talking to the guy in chat
who's saying, "Well, it's not saying it's whack." I go, "But
that's a clip of him literally saying it's whack." Hold on. I'm
looking for Listen, this is the part that I don't like with the
whole There is stuff to criticize here. I think people take it
to another level for no reason. You can get him on X. Why do
we have Yes, he stayed after seeing a child. Ahsokotano Gaming
says, "No, I believe he says right after this that he left immediately."
I think Ken cut that out. [__] Yeah. Yeah. I'm pretty
sure he says, "I left immediately because I was uncomfortable
to pretend it's why to the I'm talking to the chatter." Like
X is X is funny. We can laugh about X, but Y doesn't exist. So
why talk about Y? Cuz then he's like then you lose out on X.
Okay. So I'm going to send you some more links. So there's this
right here. Sure. He dead sound
of that. Off this one. Okay.
So, done. That's not boogie. Stavarios.
I know. Diddy's into stuff like that. THD. Okay. It's over. 100%.
He does. All right. We're going to scroll back a little bit.
Okay. Glasses with the slits through, bro. The the hater shades,
the hater blockers, the stunners. Oh my god, dude. That would
be so sick. Yo, I know Diddy's into stuff like that 100%. Sunglasses.
He does like crazy stuff like that. I feel like if you [__]
enough, it's like you kind of want to do some [__]
like that. Although, I've never I can't What is that, Dan? That's
him sounding like he knows what goes on at a Diddy party. And
when this video
is God, dude. Dude, this is just so shameful. Like, how do you
do this embarrassed like Dan? Oh my god. If if Nick were a real
gamer, he'd open that naked ape video up right now. If if Dan
weren't so honest about the fact that he's just wanting to totally
lie and it wasn't so funny watching him do it, then I would be
disgusted right now. But I I actually find it quite funny. Yo,
the worst part is not even the clips. He's doing this on like
Nick's stream cuz he wants it to get attention. This is like
so horrible. Yikes. If he if he was better at it, it would also
disgust me. Even if he'd stated somewhere that it was his opinion,
but he's like so bad at it so often that it like becomes its
own comedy act. It's very funny. Like it it just wraps back around
to just being very funny watching him like not sell these points
at all again. That what are they talking about? What is that
stuff?
What is he into?
What kind of crazy?
I don't know. How the would I know? Because it's your clip. Hold
on. It's not my color. Wait, you expect me to understand the
clip I'm using to malign this song on? You expect me to understand
what's actually going on here? Daddy with Julia Fox. Let's do
it. She's so pretty. All right. They need to know that they will
never be worthy to have that like the they'll never be good enough
for Wait, what is the music? Okay. Uh, super villain for good
enough for the They need to know that they will never be worthy
to have that like they'll never be good enough for the watching
or something. The foresomes. Yeah. Forsomes. Okay. They're talking
about foresomes. Thank you. You can't if I So Diddy is into forsomes.
Does like crazy stuff like that. I feel like if you enough it's
like you kind of want to do some [__] like that.
Although what is this from? Maybe it is saying didd he like said
groups. All right, we can slow it back. We can go back to normal
speed. I just needed to know the context of what he's into. And
by the way, Dan, are you saying that people who are into forsomes
are like potentially like No, I'm not doing that. What I'm saying?
No. Listen to me, you dumb your boy. I I feel like Dan's not
doing as bad a job as Nick is making it seem now. Now Nick is
like kind of pressing him and it's funny. I think Dan's saying,
"Why does Sissan have intimate personal knowledge of what Diddy's
into?" I don't know when the time of the clip is. That would
be significant to know. Okay. But that's what he's trying to
say. Pretending he doesn't understand that. Yeah.
Bastard. Okay. You pizza. Well, I'm just saying your other co-host
is the most person I've seen in my entire Oh, [__]
I am trying to make a point here that Hassan will go on and on
calling me Diddy Dan over and over again because
No, no, no. Even though I've never met them, but this guy and
I'm about to send you I think another clip here where Hassan
Diddy. He's never met Diddy. His girlfriend was going to go to
a Diddy party and he broke up with her. Didn't Dan doc someone
who tried to link him to Diddy? Yes, he did. Hassan's uh some
I think it was like a Hassan secondary editor. Yes. on the spot
because he he knew what was going on was at diddy parties. I
think that's this one though. Let me make sure. Wait, can I finish
this clip? Wait, that was Wait, you brought me to this clip for
one sentence? Yeah, basically that was it. Dan, I've never if
I I just can't imagine wanting to see a guy my wife. It's just
there's something in my brain like Listen, do you agree? I feel
all right. Dude, this is literally an average Tuesday at DJ.
If my wife wants to watch me, And that's the thing. I understand
that that's unfair. Yeah. Yeah. No, no. And if she doesn't want
that, that's fine. But I just Is Dan just going to let that slide?
Dan's just going to take that like water off the back, I guess.
Water off a back. It is really that villager where it's like
we were our our genes were meant to be, you know, I'm meant to
be picking olives. You're meant to be You pulled out the thing
that can find every single time he ever said the word diddy.
That's how you have this clip. Maybe. Yeah. Okay. I'm looking
for one and I can't find it right now. So, you're just going
to have to take my word. What do you mean I have to take your
word for? I didn't like your word in the last two clips. Um,
I'm trying to find it. God damn it. The the cliffnotes of it
is that it's a story of Hassan breaking and has already taken
the position that Destiny is a gross pervert, but he doesn't
care. Okay, then him moralizing over Hassan being a gross pervert,
although he hasn't even proven it yet. Is obviously right. You
can't just say, "I like this guy, so it's okay. My gross pervert
cool, your gross pervert bad." Well, you I mean you can and he
does that is exactly what he's doing, but you shouldn't up with
his girlfriend because she wanted to go to a diddy party and
he didn't want to go because he knew what went on at a diddy
party, meaning people like crazy and then he broke up with her.
Someone in chat is saying Dan is actually right about the clip.
That is that is it. But I mean, I don't think it's about people
like crazy. I think it's literally like if my girlfriend's going
to go to a celebrity party where they're literally bringing girls
like to Beverly Hills to them. That's the point of you going
to a dinner party, then I'm going to break up with her. I assume
she's going there to get I think that's like his point broadly.
You ever watch Entourage? Do you want your girlfriend going to
one of those parties without you? Probably not.
I don't know what they could be playing. You don't know. They're
going to just They could have been playing Smash or something.
They could be dancing. Yeah, I'm trying to find this goddamn
thing. Dan, Dan, you are hyper.
You are You have Hassanitis. Okay. I can't I need to take I'm
taking it with a grain of salt. It might be right, but I can
take it at a grain of salt. It is It is right. I just I'm having
a difficulty.
I'm
Assan is like he scrubbed it. He doesn't want the world to know
about his girlfriend. Hold on. I'm going to find it. I'm going
to find it. Okay, dude. He's going to pull up a clip and Assan's
going to be like, "So, I was coated in baby oil and I didn't
even know who I was." And I'm going to be such an
I got it cuz I don't even know who I was. I was just slipping
into whatever was next to me right there. I was like, "Oh, yes.
I didn't even know this one was here." Yeah. I just I I don't
think that I just I don't think that Hassad was like, "Woo, got
to go to the party." Um I think that him lying and getting caught
lying about it is funny, but I don't think there's anything nefarious
here. Uh I think I got it. Even the raided the brothel thing
is like a little weird because I don't think that like that is
as new like the wait. It's it's a little weird that they pretend
that the German government didn't apologize to their brothel
before raiding them and for like trying to build a case against
them maliciously. I thought that didn't the German government
settle with them because the German government was literally
like had no proof of this and just went after them. I thought
the German government literally apologized to that brothel. Am
I crazy? It was a cover up. The brothel was raided after he was
there. It wasn't he like he didn't set out to go wow brothel
is really young women better go to that one. There's no evidence
to support that. Hey hey it's like the biggest and most popular
brothel in Germany too as far as I know. Hey I understand everything
that you're saying. Okay. The point the point is the cognitive
dissonance that the other side will have the hoops that they
will jump through. No Hassan Per on stream calls me a Nazi. Says
I run a Nazi podcast but that's why I'm better than him. I'm
not going to call him a because he went to a brothel that got
raided after he got there. And I'm not going to say that he wants
to young kids at Diddy's party cuz I'm no better than he is.
Hey, I haven't either, you dumb. No, I'm not saying you. I'm
not saying you. But that's what the chat wants. I'm not doing
it. No. Oh, yeah. That is what That's kind of what Dan's doing.
I know Dan wants to say I'm not doing it. But Dan's like literally
walking to that line and going like, "Isn't that weird? Isn't
that strange, guys? That's what the chat wants me to do. They
want to clap like seals when I call a sonic cuz he called me
a Nazi. I'm not going to do it." Can you can you do a good seal
noise? No, you clap. That's the clapping part. But yeah. Yeah,
I know. But no, but they go but uh I don't know. I'm not going
to I'm not going to ore. I'm not going to ore for you, Dan. Find
me the clip. Good. I I posted it in our message. I'm sorry. I
didn't know. We're not getting We're not getting
It's the same clip. Oh, the last linky. God, you How do you fail
clicking things? Because I would like the He dress I couldn't
tell if he was dressed as like a knight or an orange. It kind
of looks like he's an orange. He's Hercules, isn't he? Just Hercules.
And this is the girl from Hercules.
You're doing like a duo Hercules cosplay. You guys never watched
a Disney movie in their lives. That's the important part here.
Yes. I don't know. I'm setting the stage here. You got to get
some world building going. Supposed to hang out. And I was like,
well, you know, we're supposed out that night. She was the birthday.
I'm going to go to this uh you know, this party at the house.
And I was like, we're not going there without me. What the What
do you mean? You're going to this uh you know, we were supposed
to hang out. I like that you said that though. And it was innocent.
Like it was I didn't even know what the hell was going on. Yeah.
What? This was years ago when she was like, "No, no guys allowed."
I was like, "Okay, you can go on your own." Wo, babe, I'm going.
Just a little small thing. Diddy party. No guys allowed nothing.
I'm going to be networking. Clarification. Yes, you got to clarify
the casation. Okay, so what? How do I do that? Wait, I'm confused.
I need to listen to this again. It sounds like he was like like
Hold on. Innocent. Like it was I didn't even know what he says.
The whole reason they say don't bring any guys cuz they want
a bunch of girls there so all the dudes who are there can get,
right? That's the whole point of of that thing.
I Bro, Entourage was like a documentary. Okay. He literally didn't
know it. It was in his Oh, well, if he said he didn't know, Nick,
then let's just move the on. What do you want to do as long as
you said that he knew? But the clip is him saying he didn't know.
No, he's saying like he's saying I didn't know there were kids
there, but he's still saying I knew that there were there a lot.
Yes. Wait, hold on. Do you think there's a difference? It's like
an important distinction between people had parties and had like
Wait, also is it actually the allegation that there a lot of
kids at Diddy's parties? I I get that like some of the guys were
underage and did he probably underage guys. There are like lingering
allegations of that, but I don't know that it was at the parties.
I thought it was like um people he had like power over people
he had like staying with him were like the younger guys that
he was doing that to. I thought broadly it was mostly him. Yeah.
Bieber and Usher. I think just one other guy like I thought it
was they were drugging and women drugging women and guys.
He beat a woman on camera. Yeah. Yeah. I don't know that like
super like I didn't think it was that they were bringing like
minors to these things where they're a bunch of people and then
them at these parties. I thought that was like not an allegation.
It was again depth of knowledge on the diddy stuff is probably
like a few facts. The Cassie's video and seeing his face next
to Epstein. So it seems so
broad and knowing that he was kids at these parties. Do you think
there's a difference there? Do you think it's it's unreason?
Do you think that or whatever if people went like went to a didd
diddy party you think the assumption is there were children there
or do you think the assumption was they were having a lot of
sex and when someone if your girlfriend comes up to you and says
I'm going if your girlfriend comes up to you and says hey or
your wife if someone walks up to you and says I'm going to be
going to a party with P Diddy someone you know has like group
orgies and at parties and there are no men allowed at these parties
can I I'm going to be going to this now do you think the implication
is like related to child stuff or related to the fact that like
there's occurring at these parties and the fact that they're
not allowed to bring their partners says they're going to You
are such a contrarian. You know that. Like that's not a contrarian
take. What? This is what you do, J. This is actually what you
do. Um, you disagree me. Um, you're a contrarian. That's you.
Yeah. Well, not enough. How you look? I know. You dumb bastard.
Yes. No [__] You dumb. I'm just saying that this
is a guy who will call everyone a diddy party go. They'll call
me Diddy Dan. They'll call you Diddy Oreo when this went to like
diddy parties even though he may not have known. Okay. I don't
think he did know. Probably not. But okay, there's a couple girls
who have come up with allegations to being essay at a diddy party
at 16. Wait, at a party? Kendrick, are you talking about the
people who got flown to New York and got in a recording studio?
Cuz that seems like totally totally different to me. Uh, that's
like not the party thing, but maybe there are people who are
16 at those parties. I don't know. Whole point.
We're just talking about how Hassan I would expect you to know,
Kendrick. I'm asking if I'm trying to differentiate between the
people who weren't underage got flown to like New York and got
to a recording studio because that's one of the allegations that
I know about, right? Or like an actual party at like an LA or
Miami mansion
that like that's like a big party with a big afterparty where
they're like having these group orgies and is like delusional.
You get you know he lied about going to a Diddy party. Yes. 100%.
No, that's not what I That is not what I am saying that he lied
about going to a diddy party. That is the least important part
here. The point that we're trying to make is that Hassan and
his audience have this blinders on that anything Hassan does,
it's like innocent. Like everyone was going to party. I know.
I I ran on about it the whole time. Yeah. Exactly right. And
I've never even met them. This guy's been to his parties apparently
multiple times. Right. But my point is there's probably 10% of
my chat that's convinced by this clip and he's a child and crazy.
Good. You know what? For all of you guys who are convinced, I
bet I You know what? I can't be positive, but there's a chance.
Start us in chats that Dan is just pointing out the hypoc. You
know, that is the worst part is the hypocrisy. It is. It's not
the child. It's the hypocrisy. Finally, you finally you got a
Oh my god, dude. You finally got Thank you. No, I know. I know.
Did we just demonetize? Did we just demonize? Oh, you're good.
You're good. No, he's saying, "Oh, you finally understood one
pop culture reference, Dan. Congratulations." That's all right.
I forgot certain words aren't allowed. I didn't know if like
uh if if we got there or not, but Okay, good. Good to know that
one's still on the allowed list. I'm just saying this is a this
is like a nothing burger clip with a with a clear hypocrisy.
I don't care. You remember what you care? You have begging me
to watch it. You care a lot about this clip. No, it's just to
show that Hassan and his audience are like they don't matter.
They're unserious. But I knew that before I got this weird dick.
Well, I am so sorry that I gave you an additional piece of commentary
that you didn't know about. My bad, Mr. Oreo. In the future,
I will just assume that you knew everything already and then
not send you anything. I I saw the one clip and I feel like I
got a lot mileage off that one one clip. No, the first clip that
you showed me where he said like there was a kid at this party.
It was kind of weird. I saw that clip and I I feel like I haven't
learned anything based off the other two clips that you showed
of me. One of them was just him saying the word diddy, though.
So, so I think you knew that clip sucks. But I don't know. I
don't like when Hassan goes on a live stream and says like Nick
Dioro runs a neo-Nazi podcast and he's the most transphobic person
on the planet and like grades people
and [__] I'm not a huge fan of that. I don't I don't
want to do that to him either. Well, we we're we're not doing
that to him. Yeah, I don't think we are. You think we are? Well,
I'm just saying what is the implication of the of all these clips?
Is your argument just that he's a hypocrite because he lied about
the Dd diddy party and he's both calling you diddy Didd diddy
Dan when he simultaneously has a history of going to a diddy
party and is knowledgeable the type of Okay and that's fine that's
totally fine yeah because do you know I'll tell you who hasn't
been to a diddy party or even met John Combmes let me let me
get a picture real quick hold on one second if you pull up Destiny
I'm kicking you off my stream why would I pull up what are you
I thought that's a logical place to go from there I don't know
I have I have something way better to do I like you know who
you know didn't Shan the black
has never done this I don't know if I want share this photo or
not. This is like No, I can't. This will be used against me forever.
I have to find something that I've already released. Are you
going to find this? There's a picture where they photoshopped
Diddy into it right with Dan. Picture of you when you were like
young. I'm going to find a picture of me when I took the investment.
So, that' be 2009. Tipster, can you send me that picture of you
from when you were like 22 years old? He looks completely different.
You'd never believe it was him. That guy's never been with any
party looking for like
Dan's on here talking about Hassan. Nick is like, "How can I
roll tipster into this?" I can't believe he's still doing that.
Uh, well, actually, no. They're actually friends again, though,
aren't they? I can't give you something that's like,
actually, this guy in this photo actually looks like he could
be at the party. So, no, he wouldn't be invited. He's not cool
enough. Tipster. No, me. I'm looking at photos of myself, and
it's like I think Tipster's pretty cool. All right, you know
what? Here, this photo. This is a guy that You almost said America
is dude. All right, I'll say it. This I'm saying it, dude. America,
I'm saying it. This guy was not getting invited to a Diddy party.
Okay, just take one look at him and know that there is no shot
he was on the invite list. Let me see. This is uh circa is your
argument that you were too ugly to I I was not getting invited
to this party. Yes, dude. Dan Solvin's position on this. Look
how sad I am. All right, cool. Wow. Wow.